yesterday Donald Trump used the Neil  Young song rocking in the free world  when he announced his candidacy for  president and people saying was a  strange choice because Young's song was  actually written as an anti George Bush  anthem when Neil Young wrote it that's  what he meant it to be and if you listen  to the lyrics you can tell well this  actually happens a lot this kind of  mistake  political candidates choose songs based  on their titles and then they don't  really pay attention to the lyrics until  it's too late the same thing happened  when Jeb Bush launched his campaign the  other day  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  hey thanks for watching be sure to click  subscribe to see even more great Conan  clips you may now return to your pirated  movies and creepy Japanese pornography